yeah welcome a new blitz video
five-minute playing a way out from the
swedish flag and he has a big rating 25
something in five minute is not bad at
all come on let sorry I can't help it my
wood tried and trusted exchanged Slough
I really i admit it i don't have a good
line against this lab anyway so let's
play this it's it's solid at least
hmm 97 okay the Sun gives a bit more
room for proactive play queen bee three
is the same move queen bee three okay
come on try to oh we just just placed
that okay this isn't what I have what I
have what I expected thought maybe night
to a five they are not saying this is
bad it just just not what I what I had
to had expected yeah maybe doesn't seem
it doesn't look terrible
okay maybe I can can get the the f5
bishop at least it doesn't have four
squares
now this is actually this is interesting
yeah if i take it and yeah if i take it
i don't have have a good good pieces the
night on edge force especially
especially terrible okay but a thought
maybe maybe maybe I can do we form a
form yeah I can go he can take before
yeah this is really good today let's try
to prepare you for
hmm what is your idea not to see two or
what don't know maybe
yeah it's certainly a all right for
black
you can always also play Knights you
find I probably need to take it which
isn't too inspiring anyway plus they I
exchange sex that maybe also i'm also
possible
it raw is just the preparation move for
e 5 & G for something like this scanning
space on the Kings side so then I maybe
have some sort of play I only need to
hope all the time that my queen site
isn't exploding it's got quite a quite a
good set up there already you can really
consider to take on c3 play Knight a to
something like this it's not not
ridiculous at all bond ok
tend to play h5 gaining more space ok I
want to try to attack attack the g porn
at the end
so what now some way to improve may be
here be four ninety two loops e to f of
d2
yeah I want to get to the g7 porn
mmm I thought I really thought that the
Jeep on would be would be a problem for
him yeah like here check your king here
and now the gphone isn't it dangerous I
also have this kind of stuff check
hmm I think he kept played this too hard
for a win but at least I forget it I
forgot about this move this is a bit bit
annoying okay when I can go here it's
not a big deal I just forgot that he has
this okay yeah well I don't mind I don't
mind the exchange why not can just push
now
yeah I've got two points the Jeep own as
well resign yeah well this was wasn't
the most deserved whenever he certainly
had had a very good position around here
Black is simply a much better at least
what do I know yeah well I don't know I
don't trust the computer computer gives
white an advantage I don't believe that
he has so much pressure on the queenside
I believe maybe I'm yeah there must be
something for black I mean he certainly
had to head to head an edge it's
possible yeah around here the computers
which is to black a black advantage here
to win Bishop divorce supposed to be
better though winning ok and here I'm
not sure really is this really good for
black the Jeep on is is something okay
yeah here this is Bishop e3 it this is
not easy for black I mean it's not easy
to play at all I've got this activity
and by now I'm I'm just winning here my
pawns are advancing and he's got nothing
but it's low also was very good for for
black all this yeah probably queen bee
three as a lemon here you can always
play Knight a4a three stuff like that i
was i was expecting that a5 p.m. in this
position i can show you the idea just to
show that the exchange is not always
completely idiotic if black plays b5
here which some people do then you can
actually take on d5 and just win
it's quite quite nice this is a deadly
attack already 95 and so on I've won
countless games in this fashion in blitz
okay yeah well thanks for watching
pretty nice win at the end